pour
on
syvain toutes les 10 minutes c'est ce
que doivent dégustés à l'aveuglé cinq
équipes du club d'oenologie de
voisins-le-bretonneux pour le
championnat de france l'objectif est de
trouver les caractéristiques précises
des vins dans cette feuille nous devons
mettre le cépage majoritaire
l'appellation le producteur le nom la
cuvée au cas où vraiment on a on a des
bonnes sensations et qu'on trouve là
d'excusés et le millésime qui correspond
aux vins que l'on a dégusté nous allons
déguster en général 80 blanc et 80 rouge
est sûre c'est sur ces vins là il va
falloir trouver le cépage principal
l'appellation le millésime
éventuellement le nom du propriétaire le
nom de la cub réunit un soir par semaine
les membres de ce club créé en 2005 qui
participent au championnat de france de
dégustation depuis plusieurs années
c'est un des plus gros clubs de france
avait 85 membres des grands dégustateurs
en france un plat la france a
d'une part une grosse activité viticole
mais également beaucoup d'amateurs
passionnés
et
voilà le le fort du club ici c'est la
complicité et puis aura envie d'avancer
ensemble
et puis de transmettre beaucoup de
france mène tous les vins qu'on va
déguster chacun une personnalité donc il
faut arriver à détecter tout ça un
entraînement est très important
dans notre rôle de compétiteurs servir
tournée sentir goûter tous les sens de
ses compétiteurs sont éveillés face aux
verts pour deviner mémoire et régularité
sont les mots d'ordre à prendre le verre
on va regarder le la couleur du vin là
ça va donner déjà de premières
indications ensuite on va faire une
première analyse objective
après on va faire tourner un petit peu
le vin pour avoir
des arômes qui sont plus lourds qui vont
qui vont sortir plus facilement
et enfin ensuite on va le mettre en
marche
[Musique]
des gens qui sont plus réceptifs que
d'autres bien sûr
yalla yalla actif il ya la mémoire la
mémoire qui est très importante la
grande finale devrait se dérouler en
juin prochain espérons que cette année
soit un bon millésime pour
[Musique]